okay I'm thinking that I'm going slowly
enough we may not look at this video
here you could look it up later if you
want or if it's just a two-minute video
from climate reality mmm who wants me to
try to see it oh ok well let's let's see
how technically competent we can be here
well heck dear Stephen Harper da
president jacob zuma their prime
minister in the movie they were ladies
we all know the deployment crisis is
here we can see it all around us we are
all affected by what I gotta hear how
much
dear Stephen Harper dear President Jacob
Zuma their prime minister in the movie
they were ladies we all know that the
climate crisis is here we can see it all
around us we are all affected by poor
other year hamari borrow tato we would
do something about it in fact some of us
already are miduni stage a cig Wednesday
LAN party in our businesses or still ah
now it's your turn as our leaders as the
ones without with power the power to
represent the people to represent me and
ugly and all three of us I don't forget
you please listen listen to the land
listen to the ocean listen to the
science this is some love 2015 you will
be right here in Paris at the UN climate
change conference Mikey cotton or their
mark equal to India actually we have
some demands it's a mind that you
cooperate with one another we don't want
that you send a message to pollutants
stop using fossil fuels now it's the
time the time for you to act you need to
make long-term commitments commitments
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions and
then you do the world will be a better
place instantly I want you to accustom
my future a lots riding which you decide
thanks for listening
pretty great huh so yeah thank you for
wanting to see that um let's see so that
was our video any comments on that I was
a little busy getting ready for today
but I am going to go sign that petition
after class and that leads us into what
I think you know a Dickens moment right
the best of times in the worst of times
it really is the best of times I think
what what has come clear to me just in
the course of this quarter is all the
news that I've been hearing from our
speakers from G sub from the headlines
that the world has gotten it a lot of
the world has gotten it enough of the
world to make some changes and that i
love this was something that Amory
Lovins was saying in his talk you know
as I said I've been reviewing those last
couple days do we have billions of
people who care connected by billions of
cell phones world's a little different
you know the people who just spoke to
you have like us have more power have
more ability to try to get us going in
the right direction and this stunned me
I've now heard it three or four times in
big meetings this quarter besides just
what you read new renewable energy
installations even in the US which has
been a little slow to get this have been
outnumbering fossil-based systems
fossilized I decided to be wise guy
there have outnumbered that that we have
hit a turning point and it's been in
large measure about the economics you
know it hasn't been just because you
know people finally listen to folks who
are demonstrating or anything no it's
been because people the technology has
gotten there the flexibilities gotten
there and the people who make these
economic decisions have said this is
this is right I have a thing we probably
won't have time to go to that my husband
found
we'll fill Barth who found this black
rock investing brochure online that
talks all about why you should be
investing in sustainability and it's
like wow and it's serious right it's
serious for people about that another I
think good news and you know you've
heard I really enjoyed my time at
chevron but the truth has come out about
past lives right about exons big lie and
people are understanding where some of
the naysaying has come some of the just
ludicrous denial of reality has come
from which allows us to go ahead right
and 122 countries out of the one hundred
forty some odd already made commitments
before coming to this meeting to the
cop21 meeting in Paris going on right
now I already made commitments they may
not be enough people are certainly
worried myself included that these
commitments may not be enough to avert
great harm but they've been made it's
it's better than not so as Allah sunder
is telling us behind the scenes people
are furiously working to try to make
things actually work out to make the
right decisions to make the decisions
that countries can live with and and
live up to but Wow and here's a big mix
of the best of times worst of times
right here's the photo that Doug decided
to share with me this is all the shoes
right or some of the shoes that people
left because Paris of course is under
siege they're under a state of emergency
still from the bombings the recent
bombings but you know you would being
allowed to March people left thousands
of shoes to march for them I guess and
what a typically beautiful being a
Parisian way photo that is as well
people are speaking but it's the worst
of times to write I mean it's not like
we can just go home have a beer and say
wow that was a close call but it's all
okay I know there's a heck of a lot of
work to do the thing that the best of
times is telling us is that will be
able to do it right the environment is
going to allow us I think to make the
changes we need to make so it's
difficult to see how we could possibly
stay within the two-degree limit that
people have agreed beyond the two-degree
limit we have some really horrible
consequences right it's hard to see how
we're going to stay below that in fact i
think the predictions tend to be around
2.7 and that's going to have huge
disruptions and with that comes rising
sea levels violent storms extinctions
droughts wildfires temperature rise
climate refugees situations all of that
is going to get worse before it gets
better I'm convinced that's true but I
am really amazed you know six years ago
10 years ago when I I guess it was 2006
when I got really concerned after having
seen the inconvenient truth movie I I
concluded well solar energy would be
great to get into with my skill set but
there's no way it's going to make an
impact in time and I was wrong I mean
lots and lots of people didn't think it
could possibly be making an impact in
time but it's making an impact already
so perhaps the world will surprise us
here maybe it's not going to get quite
as bad as we think but I am convinced
it's going to take many many of us the
best and brightest doing a lot of dog at
work to fend off as bad as it could get
so here we are back to the MIT
greenhouse gamble I know I showed you at
the beginning and back in two thousand
six this was the prediction of what the
probabilities were that we could stay
you know within a certain temperature
limit and by the time that this is what
it's at now on just a few years later it
was to this meaning that by their
estimate there's almost no chance that
we're going to stay below three degree
temperature I see and what does that
mean to us I know I showed you this too
but I was really struck by a couple of
summaries students wrote just how big an
impact it was on you so it seems worth
saying again that it makes a large
difference whether we stay below one
degree or
two degree or three degrees C rise you
know it isn't that well if the
temperature rises it all we're doomed
and that's it and give up or if we stay
below you know if we stop rising you
know stop emitting now we're okay know
the consequences get progressively far
worse the more we let this get out of
hand so the action you know people who
are worried well maybe the CEO PE
agreements aren't going to be good
enough you know they're going to still
let us get up to 2.7 degrees and maybe
more those are those are valid worries
that really makes sense to think about I
showed you this on the first time I'm
not going to do it again but if you come
back in sight or want to look at this
you can it just shows you it's a good
way to help answer deniers if there's
still any left that you know what it is
that's actually warming the planet and
you can add it piece by piece the IPCC
also as I showed you at that point is
showing you co2 on the rise Arctic
summer ice diminishing you know you know
the story I'm including this just in
case mainly in case somebody online is
watching this and wants a little bit of
context right the projections of what
our sea level rise are or pretty dire
and there's our good old denial right
and rising sea levels and a reminder
there is no co2 techno fix right there's
no easy way that we're seeing to get co2
out of the air now now we've had some
interesting talks about ways that might
but they're not you're not ready yet
it's it's a good thing to work on but
they're not ready yet the acidification
is a problem to one of those links that
I gave you a few slides ago of
Constance's talk year or two ago is
another interesting way to try to use
co2 the jet stream is still destabilized
we still have severe storms we still
have horrible extinction rate happening
we're right we've just begun into the
sixth wave of extinction
and it's serious but here we are the
entrepreneurs the technologists the
people who made the financial decisions
to bring in better energy sources have
really done amazing work so that things
are better than we think and the
forecast did underestimate the
possibilities for change so it's all
coming through and this is the big thing
I learned this quarter I mean this is
headline news how much better solar cell
efficiencies have become how much more
it's been adopted and the wedge somebody
was also in their summary talking about
you know define where we have to get and
then wedge by wedge approach it yes I
know I showed you this to the Earth's
energy balance and what ice 911 does
what geoengineering approaches in
general do is they start looking at how
can we reflect or deal with some of the
radiation in particular of course let's
invent it if if the YouTube people are
kind what I want to say is we've had
some interesting talk here especially
Kimberly we fling about how you design
how you really design what a person
needs rather than you know go for the
glamorous techno fix you think would be
intellectually satisfying to do or
fixing a problem without diving in and
this is one that really got it and if it
will come up for us that would be good
oh come on what really really okay fine
this is why we never assume let me tell
you what this would show you I had the
honor to be in a brainstorming session
at Summit public school which is a
really good charter school near here
where they had dr. Frederick fert who
was the global program manager for
innovation and creativity Google can you
imagine that it's like let me come to
this session I mean oh that was just
pretty great and this is one of the
things he showed us and what this is is
in not sure it's in the Philippines that
might have been
there were these communities that we're
living in basically you know it was
certainly not a rich area living
basically in shipping container type
houses you know metal boxes pretty much
and within these they had no light in
the in the daylight in the daytime so
they'd go inside and there's nothing
they could do in there they trip over
each other you know so you're living
basically outside when it's light and
you're going in there only for shelter
at night so you need light right but
like takes money it takes energy it's
it's hard to get and what this guy did
was he went around with a little saw
they'd saw a circle out in the roof and
he would fill basically a calistoga
bottle full of water and a little bit of
bleach I guess so it didn't get mold and
he put that in and he'd seal it up so it
wouldn't leak in the rain and when the
Sun shone this reflects out this shines
out through the bottle lights up the
whole house it's like a miracle so if
you can find this video when somebody
isn't complaining about copyright
infringement it's really a kind of
humbling thing you know you can work on
really complicated technologies but if
you know what people really need and you
make a couple simple observations you
can have a profound effect on people it
will cost almost nothing so that's one
to keep in mind so with that in mind I
had a rather simple idea are there any
questions before we go into ice 911 just
in general about what we could and I
know we raced through some of this along
with geo engineering and all kinds of
things at the beginning of the quarter
but here here we go because you guys
wanted to hear a bit more about this so
the thing that struck me when I got very
concerned about climate back in 2006 was
just like wow what can somebody with my
background do what on earth and I
finally came on to this ice albedo
feedback effect the thing that's making
that 34 second video of doom that you
saw at the beginning of the class happen
is that the faster the more the ice
melts bright ice the faster what's left
will melt because in the meantime the
ocean is getting warmer your area of ice
is getting smaller your roading not just
from the sides but from underneath and
if you squinted that the right way
that's a materials problem and that's
the way i decided to squint at it so
it's like what on earth could i do to
try to effect that that would be a
practical thing and my thinking was it's
a back-up plan and some of you actually
our distance learner in particular was
asking how do you even start something
like this I started it in my kitchen I
started it in my home office I started
it just walking around obsessing about
this it's like what could it be at that
point we had a huge daisy garden in our
front yard in fact I think you gave us
the first ones that they took over white
daisies and you start thinking wood
floating daisies on on us do it you know
what cheap material I was just thinking
all kinds of crazy things maybe maybe
calistoga bottles we should have a
cottage industry roping calistoga
bottles together painting and white
sending them off to the Arctic terrible
material for this button way but you
know just thinking broadly about what on
earth would help this situation and so
that's that's where this began it was
just thinking and web cruising you know
in between consulting gigs just what on
earth could make this better and I
really thought this was the backup plan
I hope we would not need but it was like
you know if humanity does what humanity
usually does which is not take action
until our backs are totally against the
wall then we're going to need some
options and then we're going to need
some band-aids can we make an option
that's going to be easy to undo but
practical to do in case we really need
it and characterize it in advance of
need and so it's as simple as floating
what it came to eventually was hollow
glass spheres and floating things like
this in water was basically the
summation of the concept and it's it's
you know thinking of that plastic bottle
lightbulb it's not that subtle an idea
but what's appealing about it is it's
harmless it's relatively cheap daisies
by the way I thought my gosh daisies
grow so well what if we had daisies
taking over the entire planet on every
coastline of the world if these seeds
got away and I decided that was probably
not a good plan the vocabulary word here
I have been accused of never explaining
this is albedo and that's basically
reflected me so it's a scale it goes
from 0 to 1 1 is a hundred percent of
your light is bouncing back 0 is none of
it is and basically open ocean absorbs
about ninety-five percent of your
sunlight at least at normal incidence
you know oblique it changes a little and
ice reflect about ninety-five percent so
absorb about ninety-five percent
reflects about ninety-five percent why
is this important so many reasons but
one of them the one that grabbed my
attention first was it back in 2006 they
were saying that twenty percent of
global temperature rise so about a fifth
of it was due to the fact that now in
the Arctic in the summer while the sun
is shining on the ice or where the ice
should be more of it shining on open
ocean so things are warming up more so
about twenty percent of global
temperature rise was coming from us
taking in more summer sunshine than we
used to and now the last that I have
heard the estimates are more like about
a third so we've gone from twenty to
thirty three percent of temperature rise
coming from this one effect so it's big
effect so if you're thinking about it
you want something that's going to be
fast and removable if you need it to be
and you know that one person could make
some kind of impact on in their spare
time that was the one I chose wow that
would be a huge effect so that's the
idea yeah right ten percent of the
world's ocean areas in the Arctic and
Antarctic it's a big deal so this twenty
percent is out of date this is an old
slide but it's worth it's worth showing
and this was you know the IPCC oh I've
scaled it with
changing and sorry I tried to add from
two thousand seven to twenty twelve but
it was it was dire what happened there
basically that we're down to about fifty
percent of the original area of the ice
with in just the last three decades and
we're down to about twenty-five percent
of the volume and it's far far worse
don't do that it's far far worse than
the IPCC fourth assessment predicted
where the average of all that is the
redline the average what they predicted
but what actually happened was worse
than their worst prediction and that's
been a problem right when you get a lot
of people trying to make a consensus
report you tend not you tend to want to
avoid being labeled as an extremist and
you tend to get a consensus view they
could be conservative so that's that's
what's gone there so it's been its
accelerated a lot faster there's a nice
write-up in Fast Company that came out
about our work about a year ago that I
liked he puts this very very coherently
so if you look this up I think you can
find it on our ice 911 website you can
see this I seem to be in some sort of
time thing where it wants me to move
along and so what we did you know
getting the advice of everybody I could
get at Stanford and beyond who knew
climate because I know I'm a chemical in
an electrical engineer specializing in
MEMS talk with all the climate guys and
try to get some advice I kept getting
very positive feedback Steve Schneider
and Terry root were the first climate
experts i talked to arm and colin heads
up the cleaner task force in boston was
one who gives just a beautiful quote
from this he's part of our governing
board now for ice 911 you know that this
is important to try to address this and
nobody else was trying to address it
like well okay you know remember I'm an
inventor uncomfortable with kind of
being up there so that's what we've been
doing and so there it is in summary
again what we're trying to reduce this
having blocked out all the buoys and
thing
this is where we were just as recently
as 1980 a lot of bright reflective ice
in June of 1980 by June of 2002 not so
much actually you know let me be clear
about this what is really shown here
this is from some work by Ignatius rigor
and John Wallace at University of
Washington and what they were really
looking at was age of sea ice but the
age corresponds very well to the
brightness and so when they made the
scale of brightness in here it's it's
pretty convenient for us Wow I'm sorry
about the timings here and so what you
can see is open ocean very absorptive of
sunlight first year ice you know you've
probably seen it glare ice ice on a
skating rink that's trying to be pure
very transparent but by the time you get
to multi your ice it's had a chance to
melt and reform numerous times and it
gets air pockets and liquid pockets and
this is what and you've seen Doug stabs
pictures right all these lumps and bumps
this is what gets you brightness this is
what gets you high reflectivity and this
is what we need here's a handy place to
say that's as far as we got we've done
an experiment up in barrel that's that
little pointy bit and if Doug stop gets
his way to help us one plan I have is to
try to help the loss of ice that comes
out here and the Fram Strait and I
think's fall bard is over there and he's
trying to get us in to work with the
university there because a lot of bad
stuff is happening in Greenland so this
is where as in standing water for two
weeks over 90 plus percent of
Greenland's area in the summer of 2012
and in 2012 here we are I challenge you
to find much right ice left anymore in
June whereas just three decades before
it was it was all over right i mean here
we are boom boom boom so that's what ice
911 is trying to fight how do you do
that while you take these bright
materials and even better material than
the one that i'm passing around is a
finer powder that you can
also float on water um it's it all
though yeah cost versus how they're
performing it's all a pretty big balance
here would you stop this but the idea is
that you can you've seen as it floats
around you can you can float it on water
but it may be less complicated in
deployment and politics to put it on ice
itself on thin ice so that you know
where it is you can fence it in a little
bit easier and you can show people you
know we're going to contain it here
that's probably a little safer while
we're making sure there's no untoward
impacts on anything and it's probably
politically a lot easier so this is the
idea you take some area you could float
it on the water you could float it on
the nearby ice you could perhaps slow
down the melt on glaciers themselves on
on places like Greenland where you get
these big areas of pooled water that get
heavier and heavier and finally crack
through the ice below and lubricate the
slide of a big sheet into the ocean and
you can just keep things cooler we've
known from the beginning that doing this
helps you keep water cooler it was part
of the aim and now as you'll see in a
couple minutes we're looking at this to
try to help with California's drought as
well it has other applications it may be
helpful for snow preservation although
one of the things that we've noticed
over time is that snow is very bright so
if you put this on snow yes you can
conserve snow but the impact if you get
anything that's a little bit darker than
this I guess this works really well
actually you get anything that's a
little darker than this like what I'm
sending around right now you actually
are behind the game because of its
darker than snow it's going to melt its
way in so there's a number of materials
that are cheaper than this that would be
very very tempting after albedo isn't
quite high enough to help on snow but on
young ice on young guys it could be very
helpful and open water could be very
helpful so
yeah yeah you did what right you and I
talked about those yep we did yeah so
what are some of those we'll get to it
what we'll get to it okay there is a
slight on it I went through the
cleantech open nice 911 was the first
nonprofit the cleantech hope to never
solicited or accepted and that's
interesting because the cleantech open
is all about building profitable
businesses from your clean tech ideas
and this one is rather unrepentantly no
we're saving the Arctic and you run into
this whole tragedy of the Commons issue
where who is going it's for everybody so
why should my country pay why should I
pay and so for years I was saying you
know we'll get to the for-profit things
later but the ice is urgent let's get
that developed first and I have finally
come to my senses David and there's a
for-profit up application that we're
pursuing as well but I think it was very
important to get this going the
important thing when you're doing
something like this and if you remember
Terry roots you can look back at Terry
roots lecture from a year or two ago
which was brilliant or look at the
slides that I showed in the first
lecture refers there's always these
unintended consequences when humanity
does anything that seems even dirt
simple you know we're going to introduce
oh I don't know wolves to take care of
the over population of deer or whatever
you end up with these cycles of things
you think you understand and suddenly
there's this unintended consequence and
it's horrible and so I've been just
adamant from the beginning make sure
that what we do we can undo I think if
you're ever going to muck on things you
know try to alter things on a large
scale you've just got to live with first
do no harm and be able to undo what
you're doing because there will be side
effects I don't know what they are yet
but there will be and if you decide the
side effects are worse than the Cure
you've got to be able to undo it so
that's been one of the things that I
think we've contributed to the
conversation and that you know I keep
showing you that fragile bubble that is
the
earth of what will you carefully try
that that's where I live from of course
doing nothing is a bad option and when
people say what's the Eco impact of
putting this material out there it's
like okay there will be some surely we
don't see much they'll certainly be
something but what's the Eco impact of
having the ice disappear you know it's
we've seen this I'm sure we talked quite
a bit in Week one about geoengineering
options and this is a kind of
geoengineering but because we're so
adamant about this this kind of
technique is being called soft geo
engineering or Steve Schneider labeled
at eco engineering and the thing that I
like about this is there's a prayer you
can do it and undo it you know imagine
if we succeeded beyond our wildest
dreams and we drove the world into the
next ice age is that good when I was a
kid that's what we thought was coming
this was a nice ice age so let's say
this is temperature and we've
overcorrected it I think we're okay on
this though because we are very very
good at sort so I think we can undo that
and what I would love would be if the
arguments down the road become where
should we make that set point of just
right why given all the good news that
I've been saying of you know this is the
best of times people are getting we're
getting renewable energy options why do
I still spend my nights and weekends on
this and that the answer to that is I
think we're still not going to get there
fast enough to not have some great arms
and if we can slow those great harms by
doing things like this I think it's
still worth doing so that's why I'm
still at it how we've done this we've
done well this this too is an old slide
we've done at least seven years of field
testing now this is a pond in Minnesota
that we know and love and there's
there's a Tony who's pond it is and we
put various materials out there and
we've been testing testing testing first
little five foot squares actually before
this I was testing up in the Sierra you
asked how do you get something like this
going
in the Sierra I would just hop in my car
you know before sunrise I would bomb up
there and see on the lake where we've
gotten permission to test how did it
look before sunrise I'd take manual
measurements I do that I did just
whatever I needed it I'd come back down
and I would have sacrificed one day that
week to this cause if you're willing to
volunteer and you make sure what you're
doing is inexpensive you don't really
you know all you need is permission to
work there after a while though if you
want to scale up you've got to start
getting some funding fortunately I've
had people who have made donations we're
now a 501 C 3 and we get instrumentation
and travel covered to do this we're in
the middle of another fundraising thing
oh and this is my time I didn't make a
slide if anybody wants to come to a
fundraiser we've got one week from
tomorrow so wednesday night at the
ladera community church seven pm and
that will be helpful and hopefully get
our end of your fundraising done for the
next adventures so here are some of the
things we've done on this Minnesota pond
the last couple years and in fact this
year again been out there a few weeks
ago segmenting the pond with Tony and
getting ready to put our materials out
trying to bury our thermocouples this
year before the freeze but
instrumentation was complicated and the
problems of working with a mostly
volunteer team persist nobody has time
to get it really solid before it's you
know before the freeze comes for
instance so it's there's challenges this
year we really need to move the funding
up to where we can have some really
regular full-time people that's that's a
big game because the world actually does
need this we've done tons and tons of
experiments here this was the 2013
version here we are in the 2015 doing
some more and we keep finding just
phenomenal results sorting out here's
one where that material i showed you
that isn't quite as bright as snow you
know it actually drills its way into the
ice but the very bright stuff as you go
through freeze-thaw cycles keeps
percolating to the top because it floats
it actually turns out to be great this
was a year ago it
mmm two years ago in a segmented way
that isolated it from the whole rest of
the pond and we ended up finding that we
had lots of ice left after I said melted
everywhere else under this particular
material we also got to Barrow Alaska
this year you know here's one of the
great things about sacrificing your time
to something like this you get to go on
some whopping adventures and getting to
be on the back of sleds with eskimo
whaling captain and his crew was really
pretty yeah I must say as I'm clinging
on to this thing and we're flying
through and I've got my balaclava and
because I'm freezing and they've got
their jackets unzip cuz you know it's
not as cold as it had been I'm alive
it's it's great fun you must have his
fun to write it's just but the logistics
were difficult here and so we found you
know things things were tough getting
the Wi-Fi signal where where they
thought there was one getting the right
GPS coordinates was complicated we got
some very interesting images but in
shifting things the way that we needed
to we're not sure which came from which
material we know this family of material
certainly helps but it ended up being
qualitative more than quantitative and
for this season at least we're back in
Minnesota we may gear up and go back to
Barrow it was a really good experience
but you know again limited funding you
have to make these these decisions this
was very interesting what Satish the
instrumentation volunteer from forever
did of having beautiful boxes for the
cameras and for the albedo sensors what
what's our wide area deployment cost
estimate because that's one of the key
questions everybody always asks it turns
out that it's our bigger I forgot to
update that particular line to ignore
that line it turns out that our best
performing material is actually more
expensive than what I used to be
estimating with but we've got years of
data now so we can see that and so now
the cost of saving
something like a 50,000 square kilometer
chunk which is huge it used to be the
historic summer to summer ice melt back
in the 90s lately we've been melting
choices which is that sorry 20 times as
much as that nonetheless it's a good
size to think of it it's a size to make
a reasonable plug between Greenland and
fall bar that the the Fram Strait that
would be a reasonable plug comes out to
something like a billion dollars if you
sorry 11 billion dollars if you want to
get that size covered it might be worth
doing but that's the sort of thing we're
doing is getting what are the basics
here do we decide we want to do that
when you're thinking that every coastal
city in the world is starting to spend
things on the order of a billion to 10
billion of dollars per year to shore up
their basic infrastructure against sea
level rise this might be worthwhile
right and and the idea is that you could
rebuild if you can reboot if you can
slow down the ice loss from the Arctic
and let it reboot itself naturally by
just giving it a little bit of a boost
the idea is you just need to nudge it
for a little while so for a few years
that's the thought here's where we've
experimented so far Alaska one year in
Canada working with a nice expert couple
spots in California Minnesota possibly
probably going on two main soon so the
cleantech open again this is an old
slide we were the first nonprofit we
became semi-finalists in 2013 we became
finalists in sustainable Silicon Valley
2014 it's about what we need is three
million five million dollars would get
us a long long way we could get this
established cleantech open we had a
really good mentoring group one of whom
had a sort out exactly what David was
asking about what is it we're trying to
do my focus has historically been on
this what we call public uses the things
for which we're not sure there's any
particular person
who's going to pay but they affect the
whole world so this is the idealist here
working on this because man it matters
you know when the sea ice is gone sea
levels storms it's just going to be bad
the commercial uses we've had in mind
all along here's a couple of the prime
ones I kind of act out some of the
others and what's nice about these is
they're practical and they're there's
something that people would really want
to pay for and especially since
California has been so obliging is to
have this horrific drought for the last
few years we've started working
seriously on that one of your coal
auditors who isn't here right now
because of a consulting deadline alex
has has been helping a ton in ice 911
doing some really good measurements on
water conservation and we were swarmed
at the most recent cleantech open event
where alumni got to exhibit and we got
to show our our data and how good this
is and you know people are really
interested cleantech open is interested
in for-profit solutions and this this is
one as I've said we've known for years
that what we do cools things and so it
turns out if you start deliberately
measuring that for drought applications
people do get interested it's actually a
win you know I've maybe been a little
slow to pick up on this because of
limited time and really knowing how
important the ISIS but it's really a win
in that when not if when we get the
right permitting and connections to work
on a fairly large sized lake to look at
this probably in California Minnesota
isn't the right climate for it we fast
but probably in a spot in California and
get to experiment with this and show how
safe the materials are and affordable
and reasonable this then will help the
acceptance and the development of the
materials to let us go ahead and save
the Arctic as well and so we've been
using that yeah slightly different team
mentioned here same same good quote same
sort of picture but what we've been
aiming for is
is this horrible need we have in
California's reservoirs and lakes and
why is this in advance and if you all
know that's right we've been living it
why is this good there's a couple things
that are really a nice feature about
this the infrastructure as you're trying
to build a reverse osmosis plant or a
reservoir it takes a long time it takes
billions of dollars to get these built
what we're doing is we're going ahead
and just saying you know we've got
materials sometimes we should grab that
sometimes we can make pancakes out of
them if we want which is a little more
work here's teeny teeny prototype
pancakes but imagine making pancakes
that are large enough that you can now
suspend these from a deliberate spot in
your reservoir and it can just stay
there and nobody's worried about whether
fish might eat this right sure enjoy
yeah they're safe that's the point
really this is something that we think
is pretty exciting and this is there's
Alex working away on ah come on let me
stay there working away on various
wading pools that we have out in the
parking lot of our consulting company to
measure how much better are we doing
than say a control there was something
so the costing that I was doing a couple
years ago was or a year ago was it looks
like we come in at being able to sell
water doing this the water that we can
serve at half the cost of conservation
and efficiency measures and those are
usually the cheapest water you could get
right and about a tenth the cost of the
desalinization without having to do the
upfront giant capital intensive costs
and then there was this wonderful thing
that happened last summer how many of
you read about the shade balls down in
la la to be right lots of prep
these guys used these 4-inch is this why
I brought the persimmons if anybody like
the persimmon bread I brought five
persimmons to give away these people
used 54 inch sorry five persimmons
4-inch four inch black plastic balls
reinforced with carbon black so they
wouldn't degrade in the Sun and floated
them on this la reservoir and the idea
was if you think about it what they did
they had these videos right I guess you
guys probably saw him rolling these
things into the reservoir cost millions
of dollars and what they're basically
did was they were reassembling a pool
cover great but a pool covers job not
only is to reduce evaporation you also
want it to warm your pool and it does an
admirable job of that and it does it by
reducing your evaporative loss by it by
allowing you not to have any evaporation
at all what we've done so we filed
patents way back when you know I'm an
inventor on our ISO 911 things and we
would never charge anyone to save the
Arctic I mean that no but it covers
cooling applications too and what's nice
about this although it's really patent
examiner's having a hard time with this
by allowing evaporation to occur because
we're cooling it's reducing evaporative
loss because we're cooler and this is
this is the trick here and what's nice
about that compared to what's here with
these shade balls a it's a whole lot
less expensive we're about a 70th of the
cost and B we're not killing fish last
summer also in the Pacific Northwest
there was washington state had one sort
of salmon the one and a half million
salmon die because they were getting
boiled to death in their lakes and
rivers if we did this and Gulf of
Maine's having similar problems I'm
hearing but it's just it's just horrible
if we put our kind of materials there
instead we too would reduce evaporative
loss but we do it by keeping things
cooler so it should be a whole lot
easier on wildlife so this is this is
our trick and this is
what we hope eventually our patents are
allowed and so what we found is that
we've cut just you know short term tests
in a parking lot very small scale
remember when you're operating small
scale you're never going to show the
full extent of how good you can be
because it's all edge effects right it's
like well yeah but it was really warmer
than it should have been because we were
leaking heat in around the edges of the
pool so this should be understating how
good we could be but we were cutting
water laws by twenty six percent over
the course of our slightly less than a
week test and that was comparable to
what they were doing the shade balls in
this big old reservoir and we kept our
peak temperatures a lot lower and
there's a question the shade balls were
actually not putting to reduce
evaporative losses they were fighting to
stop our reaction that was that chemical
reactor what's true a few years ago but
I don't think that was the
implementation this summer this summer
was about the stopping the evaporation
was stopping a UV reaction so that's why
I was flat oh that was so I read about
that one a couple years ago and I think
what they were doing this year was was
trying just to conserve water but you're
right to point out you're right to point
out that other use the only thing I
could read this year about it was it
last longer in the Sun but okay this
article just this fall actually say I is
that as soon as I came out the most
recent version but could it not yeah
these guys appeared a couple years ago
I'm thinking it might be the same
company and right there was some I
suspect a chlorination that they were
doing on the I think it was a different
reservoir and they were noticing it was
turning into a carcinogen a photo
initiated reaction yeah and so they
wanted to just block the light from that
so but and then when you dive deeper
into it you find oh the world works like
you think the other things those had
been used for were called bird balls at
airports to keep
from landing on these ponds which okay
inimical de wildlife okay and was being
used in waste treatment plants to keep
things from freezing so they were
intentionally trying to keep things from
freezing so that they could keep doing
their waste treatment said oh okay it
keeps it warmer so I was feeling kind of
gratified that things work that way but
this summer was the first time I saw
them putting them in for what the
headlines I was reading were about was
was reducing evaporation because they're
desperate right for drinking water but
you're right to point out that used to
what is fed reflective materials on snow
or ice rather than sort of open water
and if you then get to relax the
constraint of needing and can float then
you get any benefit in terms of the cost
of your material it's quite a given
reflect a degree that's a smart question
asked um we've tried some materials that
aren't very floatable you know sheet
type things yeah we I've tried one of my
favorites to try was called Teslin and
what I liked about it was it was
extremely porous because I still wanted
to be able to permit evaporative loss
and that that worked really well I had
you know like feet of at least a couple
feet of snow preserved underneath this
compared to outside up on serenely where
where I worked in the Sierra years ago
the problem with it is sheets that was
the worst winter of my life charging out
there to reposition the sheets there's
no way to anchor them it's just so hard
and that means eventually it's so costly
so that was my non floating thing that I
tried the advantage that we've seen with
with this stuff you know our best
behaving stuff that's bright and floats
is that every time it starts melting a
little it this starts floating to the
top so it keeps doing you some good
whereas these that are darker and don't
float quite as much start drilling
their way in so but I think you're
asking a really good question you know
is there if you're on snow and ice and
if you don't care if it floats in fact
maybe you'd rather it didn't maybe you'd
rather it sank when you're done so you
just say okay more sand on because
basically the floating glass is sand
more sand on the bottom of the sea
that's not bad maybe there is something
we could relax there but give us ideas
you know if you think of it let me know
because we will try it as you can see
yeah you know that this is part of the
philosophy here to you can come up with
these great ideas at your desk and you
can say this is going to be it but yes
as I think just about everybody in here
who's an engineer is gonna you got to
convince me by testing it right so if
you come up with a good idea we would be
thrilled to test it and we'll keep on
doing it um so there was that and then
you're right we were keeping our
temperatures lower by like three degrees
C more than three degrees C every
afternoon in these small-scale tests and
this is profound this is consistent with
what I'd found years ago in tiny plastic
tanks on our deck so we're finding that
we're saving water we're finding well we
think we'll be able to avoid the kind of
fish die-off that's been seen and you
know if your area now is getting
torrential rains and you don't have a
drought anymore the idea is that you
could pick this up and move it to the
next round stricken area it's not like a
reservoir where it's just going to stay
there forever this is something that you
could redeploy one of the questions that
was asked was what can you do today and
there's a number and we're officially
admitted over time I'm sorry but we're
coming right into yeah that's like it
right and so there's a there's a few
useful things for you to find out you
know what I've been trying to teach you
here and all your guest lectures is how
could you start something if you come up
with an idea that you care about but
some of you are asking what can I do
short of that you know for today while
I'm thinking of that great thing that's
going to save the planet what can I do
and
eco is ian munro so he's over in Paris
his his particular startup and I've gone
ahead hey thank you for being here take
some food on the way out it's been fun
that's one way that you can get to
learning what your climate impacts are
Oro eco it's very difficult i found so
far to drill into where can I say you
know is eating red meat worse than
flying an airplane I I haven't found the
magic button there yet although it looks
like it could be there's a pages and
pages of very useful ideas there and you
can get your own sort of blueprint of
how are you doing there's terrapass
which does give you this kind they're
staying connected there's donating if
you see things you care about certainly
there's changing your career and they're
starting something new and what will you
carefully do and if you've got time to
hang around and talk over Hershey kisses
and persimmon bread please do and
somebody take these and it's been such a
pleasure knowing you guys thank you so
much
you